[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja
Hayali schönen guten Abend wenn wir im
heute journal mit dem Wetter beginnen
dann muss es schon eine besondere Lage
geben und die gibt es eine
ausgewachsene Wetterlage sogar und die
hat heute zu vielen Unfällen
Flugausfällen Zugverspätungen
herabstürzenden Ästen beschädigten
Fahrzeugen und etlichen verletzten
geführt das es in vielen Teilen
Deutschlands so viele Stunden am Stück
Regen mit Glatteisbildung gab das ist
ungewöhnlich zuletzt zu beobachten
1987 wo tief Gertrud Spuren hinterlassen
hat Stefan
Schlösser und dann kommt am Nachmittag
auch noch noch der große Schnee kein
Durchkommen mehr auf A5 und A7 am
hattenbacher Dreieck in Hessen auch
nicht für den Streudienst Richtung Süden
staut sich der Verkehr auf über 20 km
Länge eine
Katastrophe Räumdienst habe ich seit
einer halben Stunde hier nicht mehr
gesehen wir haben keine Chance den Berg
hochzukommen und mitm Container noch
schwieriger weil der Flüssigkeit drin
ist Schneeketten sind seine letzte
Chance im Süden Deutschlands kein Schnee
dafür Regen bereits am frühen Morgen auf
dem gefrorenen Boden bildet sich
schlagartig eine dicke Eisschicht jeder
Schritt eine Herausforderung eine
Rutschpartie die nicht immer gut
ausgeht die Winterdienste sind in weiten
Teilen Deutschlands seit der Nacht im
Dauereinsatz doch sie können nicht
überall gleichzeitig sein viele Orts
blieben Schulen Kitas und andere
öffentliche Einrichtungen
vorsichtshalber geschlossen wer
unterwegs war musste mehr Zeit
einplanen wir sind heute extra früher
aufgestanden ich hatte heute in der Früh
schon das Problem dass mein Auto
eingefroren ist ich musste mit M Wasser
das Auto frei machen es ist sehr glatt
auf die
Nebenstraßen trotz zahlreicher Warnungen
im Vorfeld ist es zu vielen Unfällen
gekommen auf der A8 Richtung Stuttgart
kam ein PKW in Schleudern und
kollidierte mit einem Sattelzug ein
nachfolgender Lkw-Fahrer hielt sofort an
um zu helfen und brachte sich damit
selbst in Gefahr LKW Fahrer ist
ausgestieger wahrscheinlich Hilfe zu
leisten und ist dabei dann von einem
weiteren Pkw erfasst worden angefahren
worden und dabei schwer verletzt worden
in der Eifel kam der Fahrer dieses
Kleintransporters in einer Kurve von der
rutschen Straße ab und prallte gegen
einen Baum der 34-Jährige verstarb noch
an der Unfallstelle Einschränkungen auch
bei der Bahn wie hier in München fielen
zahlreiche Verbindungen aus größer noch
die Folgen für den Luftverkehr allein in
Frankfurt wurde schon im Vorfeld mehr
als die Hälfte aller Flüge gestrichen
manchen Menschen kann es anscheinend
nicht zu kalt und zu ungemütlich sein
selbst bei diesem Wetter reitet ein
Surfer die Welle auf dem Münchner
Eisbach der Dicke Anzug hält schön warm
wie ihr seht ich dampfe kein kein weit
und breit keine Kälte empfinden gerade
er weiß offenbar was er tut die Gefahr
extremer Eisglätte geht in der Nacht
zurück doch die Lage bleibt
angespannt muss man aber auch mal sagen
es ist ja immer hin auch noch Winter
Katja horonnefer aus der Wetterredaktion
ist zu uns gekommen Katja wir haben es
gerade gehört die Lage bleibt angespannt
auch bis morgen ja wobei dieser
klatteisregen sich jetzt langsam etwas
zurückzieht ganz aktuell gibt es aber
noch gefrierenden Regen und zwar in
einem breiten Streifen der reicht von
rheinlandpfals bis rüber Richtung
Thüringen und Sachsen und auch im
östlichen Bayern gibt's aktuell
gefrierenden Regen und nördlich davon
gibt es einen großen Bereich wo es jetzt
ganz heftig schneitt also es ist vom
südlichen nordrehein-westfahen bis
hinüber Richtung Brandenburg und wir
haben auch morgen noch mit diesen
Schneefällen zu tun die dann aber
langsam aus Deutschland wegziehen
nämlich südwärts das ganze ist ja von
Süden gekommen und jetzt zieht es nach
Süden wieder zurück ganz kurz noch war
es denn so schlimm wie gestern
angekündigt ich würde sagen wir haben
uns perfekt darauf vorbereitet viele
Menschen sind zu Hause geblieben die
Räumdienste waren im Einsatz und haben
rechtzeitig alles gestreut sodass wir
relativ glimpflig davon gekommen sind
vielen Dank und dann Hof ich nicht
falsch verstehen dass wir uns morgen
nicht noch mal sehen sondern dass ich es
wirklich entspannt danke
dir zu einem völlig anderen Thema führt
der eigene eventuell auch nur der
gefühlte eigene Abstieg zum Aufstieg der
AFD seit dem Treffen von Politikern aus
der AFD und der CDU mit
Rechtsextremisten und Rassisten fragt
sich die Republik erneut wie radikal ist
die AFD wie konnte sie so stark W werden
warum wird sie trotz ihrer in Teilen
rechtsextremen Protagonisten und
Positionen gewählt und wie kann man sie
stoppen das Erschrecken über die
unmenschlichen deportationspläne ist
jedenfalls sichtbar und so gehen jetzt
auch viele auf die Straße und zeigen
Gesicht andere gehen in den Bundestag
und erheben ihre Stimme ein
Stimmungsbild zwischen Protest und
parlamentari von Klaus
brotbeck am Abend demonstrieren sie
wieder hier in Berlin gegen
Rechtsextremismus gegen die
AFD das ist eine faschistische Partei
die mit demagogischen Mitteln versucht
so viel wler wie möglich zu machen um
dann ein faschistisch Regime in
Deutschland zu errichten dagegen müssen
wir vorgehen es muss sein also es geht
nicht dass man sowas einfach so im
Stillen passieren lässt und dann
irgendwie irgendwann hups also eine
Mehrheit in Deutschland hat gelernt
aus der deutschen Geschichte und
wirklich zweites 33 wird diese
Gesellschaft verhindern am Morgen im
Bundestag Beratung im Innenausschuss
über das pozdam Treffen von Rechten und
rechtsextremen im vergangenen November
darunter auch ein noch vor wenigen Tagen
enger Mitarbeiter von AFD Chefin Alice
Weidel insgesamt zeigt sich dass dies
eines von mehreren Schlaglichtern darauf
ist dass ich die rechtsextreme Szene in
Deutschland untereinander vernetzt und
dass die AFD dort regelmäßig dabei ist
und letztlich dann auch der politische
Arm der Rechtsextremen in Deutschland
ist die AFD verursacht diese Lage sie
will ein anderes Land das ist die
verfassungsfern es ist die
Verfassungswidrigkeit es ist die
Zersetzung und auch die Kooperation mit
fremden Mächten um dieses Land zu Fall
zu bringen Redner in der rechten Runde
Martin selner Aktivist der identitären
Bewegung stellte deportationspläne vor
genannt Remigration dass ihre Vertreter
dem zugestimmt hätten so die d hätte der
Verfassungsschutz heute nicht
nachgewiesen der entscheidende Punkt ist
für die kruden über
begriffsübersteuerung des
ibaktivisten konnte an keiner Stelle
oder wollte an keiner Stelle belegbar
behauptet werden dass AFD Vertreter
diese mrügen es wurde gezielt zu diesem
Treffen eingeladen um mit Herrn selner
über sein Buch zu sprechen da stehen
keine Dinge drin die ganz verhamlos über
die Rückführung von illegal sich hier
aufhallenden Menschen spricht sondern
über ganz unterschiedliche
Personengruppen die unter anderem auch
Menschen wie mich betreffen also
Menschen die deutsche sind eine deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit haben und die hier
zwangsdeortiert werden sollen solche
Proteste könnten anhalten und die
Debatte um ein mögliches Parteiverbot
der AFD
beschleunigen wie überrascht bist du
eine häufig gestellte Frage in den
letzten Tagen an Menschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte aber die die hier
die 90er Jahre erlebt haben
rostocklichten Hagen Mölln Sprüche wie
das Boot ist voll oder Kinder stad Inder
die die selbstentharnung des NSU im Jahr
2011 beobachtet haben Halle Hanau die
Ermordung weiter Lübkes oder das
Erstarken der AFD einer demokratisch
gewählten Partei die ihre in Teilen
rechtsextrem Tendenzen aber immer
weniger verbirgt wie überrascht soll man
da über die diskutierten vertreibungsf
en sein die Empörungswelle die die
deportationspläne ausgelöst haben die
geht nun aber quer durchs Land macht
nicht mehr nur halt bei Menschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte doch was tun soll
man eine Partei die demnächst durch
Wahlen Exekutive Macht erhalten könnte
wirklich mit einem
Parteiverbotsverfahren überziehen Sarah
Tacker ichede nicht mehr von inigration
ich rede nun davon
remigrationen
die AFD ist offen gegen Zuwanderung aber
ist sie auch gegen die
Verfassung multikulturell ist
multikriminell Bevölkerungsaustausch pur
Peter Müller noch bis Dezember war er
Richter am
Bundesverfassungsgericht der
federführende Richter im NPD
Verbotsverfahren wann eine Partei
verboten werden darf das hat Peter
Müller entscheidend
geprägt das Parteiverbot ist
ultimtio des Verfassungsgericht spricht
davon es ist ein scharfes aber
zweischneigiges Schwert des
Rechtsstaates und deshalb muss
feststehen dass die ganze Partei sich
gegen die freiheitlich demokratische
Grundordnung richtet und nicht nur
einzelne die Voraussetzung die Peter
Müller und seine Verfassungsrichter
Kollegen 2017 für ein Parteiverbot
aufgestellt haben sind
klar die Partei darf nicht zu klein sein
daran scheiterte das NPD
Verbotsverfahren bei der AFD kein
Problem groß genug ist sie in Umfragen
steht sie bundesweit bei mehr als
20%. Voraussetzung 2 die Partei muss den
Kern der freiheitlich demokratischen
Grundordnung gefährden konkret
Demokratie Rechtsstaat
Menschenwürde Menschenwürde heißt jeder
Mensch ist Träger einer eigenen
unveräußerlichen würde und das ist zu
respektieren die Vorstellung deutsche
Staatsbürger äh in einer großen Zahl aus
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu
deportieren ist mit der Vorstellung des
Grundgesetzes was die Menschenwürde
anbetrifft nicht zu vereinbaren solche
Ideen sind aber bei der AFD immer wieder
zu
findend werden wir die Remigration ganz
oben auf unsere politische Agenda setzen
wer hat uns gefragt ob wir ein
historisch einzigartiges Experiment
möchten eine monoethnische Demokratie in
eine multiethnische zu verwandeln sie
haben der
umfolkungfolkung Deutschlands Tür und
Tor geöffnet Aussagen die durchaus als
verfassungsfeindlich gelten
könnten diese umfolkungsthesen sind
natürlich Thesen die Menschen
diskriminieren die Menschen ungleich
behandeln es sind Thesen die in der
Verfassungsordnung keinen Raum haben
dass es rechtsradikale und Faschisten in
der AFD gibt ist belegt aber reicht das
aus um die AFD zu verbieten W rechts
oder
und die Frage gebe ich gleich weiter an
eine Frau die sich mit der AFD so gut
auskennt wie kaum eine zweite die
Beobachtung der Partei durch den
Verfassungsschutz geht maßgeblich auf
sie zurück damals war sie Leiterin der
Abteilung Rechtsextremismus aktuell
sitzt die parteilose Juristin auf
Vorschlag der CDU im Berliner Senat als
Justizsenatorin und damit einen schönen
guten Abend nach Berlin felor badenberg
guten Abend Frau Hayali gibt es denn für
sie gute und ausreichende Gründe für ein
parteierbotsverfahren aus meiner Sicht
ähm ist aktuell ein Parteiverbot aus
rechtlichen aber auch aus politischen
Gründen nicht angezeigt die rechtlichen
Hürden für ein Parteiverbot sind sehr
hoch das hat das NPD Verbotsverfahren
vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht gezeigt
ähm insofern halte ich die Voraussetzung
die das Bundesverfassungsgericht an
einen Parteienverbot stellt derzeit für
nicht gegeben was müsste denn passieren
damit es gegeben wäre wir brauchen eine
gesicherte
Verfassungsfeindlichkeit das heißt wir
brauchen umfangreiche Erkenntnisse die
die Verfassungsschutzbehörden vorzulegen
haben um die gesicherte
Verfassungsfeindlichkeit auch belegen zu
können und soweit ist es um die AFD noch
nicht bestellt sie haben die MPD gerade
angesprochen viele sind vorsichtig wegen
des gescheiterten NPD Verbotsverfahren
von 2017 damals hie es die NPD sei zu
klein und damit zu ungefährlich die AFD
ist ja unbestritten größer könnte sich
aber weiter als Opfer stilisieren das
ist für sie ein oder kein juristischer
Grund das ist für mich kein juristischer
Grund das ist natürlich eine Rechtsfrage
mit dem man sich beschäftigen muss ist
die AFD möglicherweise zu groß um ein
Parteiverbotsverfahren in zu initiieren
aber aus meiner Sicht spielt ein ganz
anderer Grund eine wesentlichen Rolle
bei dieser Frage nämlich wir haben
dieses Jahr drei Landtagswahlen einmal
in Brandenburg in Thüringen und in
Sachsen und ich halte jetzt vor dem
Hintergrund dieser drei Landtagswahlen
in diesem Jahr ein AFD Verbotsverfahren
für nicht geboten weil es dann politisch
möglicherweise doch der AFD wieder in
die Hände spielt aber wenn der
Verfassungsschutz in drei Bundesländern
die AFD als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch einstuft hat der
Staat dann nicht doch zumindest die
Pflicht ein Verbot der AFD zu prüfen das
ist richtig Frau Hayali der
Verfassungsschutz der sammelt ja
fortlaufend
Informationen und Erkenntnisse über die
Partei und wertet diese aus insofern ist
das ein fortlaufender Prozess der ja
auch in der Vergangenheit dazu geführt
hat dass von einer prüffallstufung bis
hin zu einer gesichert extremistischen
Bestrebung die Bewertung durch die
jeweils zuständigen
Verfassungsschutzbehörden vorgenommen
worden sind jetzt ist es aber auch so
man kriegt ja Fr und Ideologie nicht
wegverboten Frage an Sie jetzt als
Senatorin wie mit demokratiefeinden
umgehen die ja mit den Mitteln der
Demokratie genau diese möglicherweise
abschaffen
wollen ich glaube es ist wichtig dass
wir den Menschen zeigen dass die
Demokratie und dass die Institutionen in
diesem Lande funktionieren wir müssen
den Menschen zeigen dass jede Stimme für
die AFD eine Stimme gegen die Demokratie
in in unserem Sinne ist wir müssen
bessere Politik machen wir müssen
insbesondere die Politik aber auch
besser erklären um das Vertrauen der
Menschen zurückzugewinnen die inzwischen
uns und damit meine ich den
demokratischen Parteien den Rücken
zugekehrt haben wenn Parteien die
Rhetorik von rechtspopulistischen
Parteien übernehmen wenn Sätze wie wegen
abgelehnten Asylbewerbern die sich die
Zähne hier machen lassen kriegen
deutsche Bürger keinen Zahnarzttermin
und weitere wenn sowas geäußert wird wie
hilfreich ist das eigentlich um wler
zurückzuholen ich glaube es ist wichtig
noch mal zu betonen dass die größte
Gefahr für unsere Demokratie derzeit von
der AFD ausgeht und da gibt es glaube
ich auch keine zwei Wahrheiten insofern
glaube ich ist es wirklich wichtig und
das würde ich mir wünschen dass alle
demokratische Parteien sich
zusammenschließen dass alle
demokratischen Parteien gemeinsam
überlegen wie man die unterschiedlichen
Probleme die Unterschied Herausforderung
dieses Landes gemeinsam sozusagen in die
Hände nehmen kann gemeinsame Lösung
entwickeln kann um wie gesagt die
Menschen die uns inzwischen nicht mehr
das Vertrauen schenken für uns
zurückzugewinnen sagt die Berliner
Justizsenatorin FAU badenberg vielen
herzlichen Dank vielen Dank
frauali und das Gespräch haben wir kurz
vor der Sendung aufgezeichnet Ende
Februar übrigens wird das
Oberverwaltungsgericht Münster über
entscheiden ob die AFD als Gesamtes ein
Verdachtsfall ist das Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz hatte diese Einstufung
vorgenommen der Bundesverband der AFD
werrt sich gegen das Urteil aus erster
Instanz und hier geht es jetzt weiter
mit Nachrichten und die beginnen Gundula
mit dem Blick in die Ukraine der
andauernde russische Beschuss der
Ukraine hat erneut harkiv getroffen
mindestens 17 Zivilisten wurden verletzt
als russisch Raketen in der Stadt
einschlugen Charkiv liegt rund 30 km vor
der Grenze zu Russland das russische
Militär behauptet immer wieder
militärische Ziele anzugreifen getroffen
und zerstört wurden aber nach
ukrainischen Angaben Wohngebäude und
eine medizinische
Einrichtung in einer russischen
Teilrepublik in
Baschkortostan ist es zu einer in
Russland sehr seltenen größeren
Protestaktion gekommen anlass war eine
Haftstrafe für einen Oppositionellen
wegen angeblich rassistischer Äußerungen
gegen die Verurteilung protestierten
tausende Menschen die Polizei ging mit
Tränengas gegen die Demonstranten vor
und nahm zahlreiche Fest der Verurteilte
Ökoaktivist hatte vor gut einem Jahr den
russischen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine scharf
kritisiert Abgeordnete des
Europaparlaments üben heftige Kritik an
der EU-Kommission wegen der Freigabe von
gut 10 Milliarden Euro an Ungarn sie
vermuten die Kommission habe sich
erpressen lassen um Ungarn zur Aufgabe
des Vetos gegen weitere geplante
Milliardenhilfen für die Ukraine zu
bewegen kommissionspräsidentin von der
Lin verteidigte die Freigabe von
EU-Geldern an Ungarn mit der jüngsten
Justizreform habe Ministerpräsident
Orban die Bedingungen aus Brüssel
erfüllt
die USA haben die hui Miliz im Jemen
wieder auf die Liste weltweit agierender
Terroristen gesetzt und Sanktionen gegen
sie verhängt grund sind die anhaltenden
Angriffe der hui im Roten Meer und im
Golf von
Aden dutzende der noch über 100
israelischen Geiseln in der Gewalt der
Hamas sollen an chronischen Krankheiten
leiden und Medikamente benötigen diese
sollen sie nun erhalten vermittelt von
Kat und Frankreich werden im Gegenzug
Hilfsgüter für Zivilisten im
Gazastreifen geliefert bei Gefechten im
südlichen Gazastreifen wurden nach
israelischen Angaben mehr als 30
palästinensische Kämpfer getötet dabei
soll auch ein von der jordanischen Armee
errichtetes
feldkrankenhaus schwer beschädigt worden
sein der bestialische Angriff der
Terrorgruppe Hamas vom 7 Oktober auf
Israel viele Experten sind sich sicher
ohne die Hilfe des Iran wäre der nicht
möglich gewesen Iran der seit
Jahrzehnten in seiner DNA
festgeschrieben hat dass Israel kein
Existenzrecht hat auf offener Bühne
bekräftigte das heute auch noch mal der
iranische Außenminister beim
Weltwirtschaftsforum in Davos und
während man sich über solch
widerwerärtigen Aussagen nur schüttelt
zündelt Iran weiter mit Angriffen auf
Pakistan Syrien und Irak Jörg Brase über
muskelspielende
mullers Rauch über dem roschalad
Krankenhaus im irakischen Erbil
montagncht Raketen abgefeuert aus Iran
ihr Ziel ein angebliches Versteck
israelischer Geheimdienstmitarbeiter im
Norden Iraks Vergeltung für zahlreiche
Angriffe Israels auf iranische Ziele
sagt heute Irans Außenminister
inav was in den vergangenen Tagen in
passiert ist also innerhalb irakisch
Kurdistans hat mit Agenten des Mossad zu
tun diese Geheimdienstagenten des Mossad
hatten vorher auf dem Gebiet Irans
operiert am abdollan nutzt seinen
Auftritt auf dem Weltwirtschaftsforum
für Drohungen gegen den erdzfeind
Israel die Islamische Republik Iran wird
mit Gewalt Antworten auf jede Aktion des
israelischen regims gegen die Sicherheit
unseres
Volkes es ist das jüngste Kapitel im
Schattenkrieg zwischen Iran und Israel
der seit vielen Jahren tobt Iran greift
Israel bislang nur indirekt an indem es
Milizen seiner schiitischen
Glaubensbrüder in der Region unterstützt
vor allem die libanesische Hisbollah
Miliz wird jährlich mit hunderten
Millionen Euro aus tean finanziert immer
wieder feuern Hisbollah Kämpfer Raketen
auf Israel jemenitische hui Rebellen
greifen mit iranischer Hilfe erst jüngst
wieder Schiffe im Roten Meer an
angeblich weil sie Waffen für Israel
transportieren Israel antwortet auf
Irans Aktivitäten in Irak Libanon Jemen
und Syrien mit Luftschlägen Rasi musawi
General der iranischen Revolutionsgarden
starb Ende Dezember in Syrien vermutlich
durch israelische
Raketen auch die palästinensische Hamas
gehört zu den Günstlingen teerans den
Angriff der Hamas auf Israel vom 7
oktober feiert Irans Führung bei jeder
Gelegenheit als großen
Erfolg ihre Arbeit ist ein
hervorragendes Beispiel für den heiligen
Krieg im Dienste Allahs und wir hoffen
dass so Gott will dieser Kampf dieser
Widerstand diese Aktivitäten fortgesetzt
werden bis zum endgültigen Sieg vor
wenigen Tagen erst wurde in Tian ein
neues Plakat enthüllt kassememani
ehemaliger Chef der Auslandsabteilung
der Revolutionsgarden der vor vier
Jahren von den USA getötet wurde
verteilt Waffen an hamaskämpfer sie
sollen tun was Iran selbst nicht wagt
Israel direkt
anzugreifen fragen wir auch noch mal
nach bei Jörg Brase in Istanbul Jörk
warum traut sich denn der Iran nicht
oder anders gefragt was will der
Iran na ja der Iran traut sich nicht
weil ein direkter Angriff auf das
Staatsgebiet Israels sicher den Kasus
belli bedeuten würde und einen Krieg
gegen die Militärmächte Israel und USA
das will Teran sicher eher vermeiden was
man aber erreichen will das ist eben wir
haben es gesehen mit Hilfe Verbündeter
schiitischer milizengruppen in der
Region also mit den hui vor allem mit
der hisbolla im Jemen Israel in einen
mehr frontenkrieg zu verwickeln Israel
militärisch zu schwächen und jetzt
befürchten halt viele dass sich Israel
dadurch zu einem unüberlegten Schritt
provozieren lassen könnte dass das den
Flächenbrand auslöst das versuchen die
USA die Vereinten Nationen das versuchen
die Europäer aber auch die arabischen
Staaten zu vermeiden und ich denke dass
Iran nach wie vor kein Interesse daran
hat in einen direkten offenen Krieg mit
Israel einzutreten das heißt deiner
Einschätzung nach würdest du auch sagen
es droht auch erstmal wirklich kein
Flächenbrand das bleibt natürlich jetzt
weiter zu hoffen aber man muss auch
sehen dass Teran jetzt unter Druck
gestanden hat eine Reaktion zu zeigen
eben auf die gezielte Tötung des
Revolutionsgarden Generals musawi in
Syrien Ende Dezember vermutlich durch
Israel und dann gab es Anfang Januar
auch einen großen Anschlag in Iran
selbst da war in der waren in der Stadt
kermern viele Menschen ums Leben
gekommen bei einem Bombenanschlag Wohl
des islamischen Staates Teran hatte mit
Vergeltung gedroht und in dem
Zusammenhang muss man glaube ich die
Raketen von Montagabend sehen Terran
wollte sein Gesicht nicht verlieren man
wollte die Anschläge von Ende Dezember
und Anfang Januar nicht unbeantwortet
lassen Einschätzungen von Jörg Brase
vielen herzlichen Dank zu den Absichten
und der Rolle des
Iran ja einen noch ausführlicheren
Einblick in die Interessen des Iran
bekommen sie gleich direkt im Anschluss
an unsere Sendung im
auslandjournal wie viel Technologie ist
eigentlich gut und insbesondere ab wann
ist der Einsatz von technischen
Hilfsmitteln wirklich richtig gut damit
beginnen deine Nachrichten
Bildungsexperten empfehlen einen
vorsichtigen Einsatz von künstlicher
Intelligenz in Schulen in einem Papier
für die Kultusminister raten sie nur
ältere Schüler mit ki-inrumenten wie
Chat GPT lernen zu lassen in der
Grundschule müsse der Fokus auf lese und
Schreibkompetenzen der Kinder liegen
zugleich brauche es mehr KI Fortbildung
für Lehrkräfte und in der Benotung müsse
die Verantwortung bei den Lehrern
bleiben Bildung Wirtschaft und
Gesellschaft werden immer digitaler der
Branchenverband BITCOM hat nun mit einer
Umfrage die digitale Abhängigkeit
Deutschlands vom Ausland erkundet Frank
betetmann mit welchem Ergebnis wie
abhängig sind deutsche Unternehmen vom
Import digitaler Leistungen ja sehr man
sei stark abhängig sagten fast zwei
Drittel aller befragten Betriebe mehr
als 20 Mitarbeitern wie seerr beschreibt
eine andere Zahl digitale Technik aus
dem Ausland beziehen in Deutschland
inzwischen 95% der Unternehmen den Stopp
solcher Importe würden die allermeisten
heimischen Firmen nur kurze Zeit
überleben heißt es in der Studie
besonders groß ist die Abhängigkeit bei
Endgeräten wie Smartphones und Laptops
die 94% der Unternehmen importieren
gefolgt von digitalen Bauteilen wie etwa
Chips Halbleitern oder Sensoren und
cybersicherheitsanwendungen wie Firewall
Deutschland ist digital also alles
andere als souverän groß ist vor allem
die Abhängigkeit von den USA und China
besonders die von China bereite sorgen
die Zahlen insgesamt sein ein wegruf für
die Politik so bit kommommen heute und
was fordern die digitalbranche und die
Unternehmen um aus dieser Abhängigkeit
herauszukommen na ja vor allem ein
Umdenken mehr Offenheit für Technologie
eine bessere Möglichkeit Daten zu nutzen
insgesamt weniger Verbote bessere
abschreibungs Möglichkeiten für
Investitionen in digitale Technik und
mehr itfachkräfte also insgesamt müsste
sich eine ganze Menge ändern so die
Branche will Deutschland nicht weiter
digital den Anschluss verlieren also
mehr Bereitschaft zu Veränderungen
vielen Dank Frank
betetmann und immer wieder mittwochs die
gewinnzahlen vom Lotto sie lauten 6 9 13
30 40 44 Superzahl 6 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf lot zdf.de und im ZDF
Text gesunde Ernährung im Alltag soll
nach Plänen der Bundesregierung leichter
werden sie hat eine Ernährungsstrategie
unter dem Titel gutes Essen für
Deutschland beschlossen insbesondere bei
der außer hausverpflegung in Kitas
Schulen Unis oder
unternehmenskantinen sollen künftig
öfter regionale Lebensmittel und Bio auf
dem Speiseplan stehen vor allem für
Kinder heißt das weniger Zucker Fett und
Salz im Essen die vollständige Umsetzung
der Maßnahmen ist allerdings erst bis
geplant solange warte ich nicht essen
folgt jetzt direkt nach Feierabend wir
gehen und die Kollegen vom heute journal
Update übernehmen Christopher wehmann
meldet sich um 0:30 Uhr und wir sehen
uns dann hier morgen wieder in der
Handballpause so gegen 2:05 Uhr machen
sie es gut wo immer sie sind tschüss bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten abend noch mal milde Luft aber
auch Regen gefährlicher gefrierender
Regen und Schnee sind mit dem Tief
Gertrud ja heute herangezogen und dieses
Tief gertrut sieht morgen weiter
ostwärts und dann übernimmt das tief
farima und bringt mit dieser kalten Luft
Regen und Schnee aus Deutschland weg
treibt das einfach nach Südosten raus
das schauen wir uns jetzt aber noch mal
genauer an denn in den vergangenen
Stunden hat es doch sehr kräftig
geschneit hier zwischen der nei und der
Eifel etwa und es gibt immer noch einen
ganz schmalen Bereich wo aktuell immer
noch dieser gefährliche gefrierende
Regen fällt dieses Band mit dem
gefrierenden Regen wird aber im Laufe
der Nacht immer dünner werden allerdings
haben wir es immer noch mit den
Schneefällen zu tun und morgen früh zum
Berufsverkehr sollten Sie sich also
wieder auf kräftige schneefäler
einstellen und zwar in rein fals und vor
allen Dingen auch in Hessen im Osten ist
es nicht ganz so heftig Regen und Schnee
werden uns dann aber morgen immer mehr
Richtung Südosten verlassen und dann
wird's zum Teil auch ganz freundlich die
Nachttemperaturen aber die sind wirklich
noch mal interessant denn es ist sehr
mild hier am oberrein mit 8° sonst
sinken die Werte auf 0 bis -5° und
morgen bleibt es mild noch mal in
Süddeutschland mit Werten von 6 bis 10°
sonst liegen die Höchsttemperaturen bei
-1 bis
+3° und morgen haben wir es mit einem
freundlichen Streifen zu tun von der
Ostsee bis zur Mosel und diesen
abziehenden Schnee und Regenfällen
einige Schauer gibt's auch im Nordosten
Deutschlands und die gute Nachricht
heute Abend ist danach beruhigt sich das
Wetter es gibt am Freitag noch einige
Schneeschauer schneeregenschauer an der
Nordseeküste aber dann gibt's ein
schönes Wochenende Sonnenschein oder
Nebel bei Temperaturen meist knapp über
0° guten
Abend